falgrim is a vast world with diverse
people
including us the foundling the brigands
and the nearby camps and many more
questionable figures
today's video is going to be talking
about the many npcs you've made through
the game and
what exactly they're doing here quick
disclaimer some of these npcs as you
will soon discover don't have too much
backstory to them so most of it will be
speculation
for example our first npc is gorf gorf
is a talking frog frog spelled backwards
is gorf
hence the name is located on the river
in falgrim before entering the seat of
infinity
and his only purpose in the game is when
you talk to him you can turn the in-game
music
on and off the only thing i can think of
is that gorf may have ingested some tar
at some point as he may have been like
some of the other frogs around the river
the ones that attack you with poison
and because of ingesting the tar it sort
of evolved him into this sentient being
and much
larger frog than the others also in
falgrim located above gorf is baghead
he's an interesting fella as he's the
only brigand that doesn't attack us on
sight
when you first meet him he wants rat and
moonshine if you succeed in finding
these for him he will have a secret
ending of fogger and being overrun by
the ghouls and
all the brigands fighting we explained
this a lot more in detail in the
previous two videos which you can see
at the end of this current video that
you're watching right now or in the eye
in the top right he also has a slight
history with teal
teal and baghead used to be part of the
same group until teel became obsessed
with tar the first person you will most
likely come across in mortal shell is a
priest woman by the name of sester
ganesa
she serves the most vital role in our
adventure sester ganesa helps the
fouling in many ways like reclaiming our
flesh so we can't die giving us items to
buy and helping us learn the stories of
the shells we possess
tester ganesa is a confusing person
though as she just shows up
and just helps us with no real reason
why magnessa was part of the seat of
infinity she was your typical sister
part of the rituals they perform
consist of drinking the nectar there
drinking the tar can cause visible
hallucinations these hallucinations are
said to be the seed of infinity's
revered gods
from talking with the old prisoner we
find out that the two actually knew each
other and that sister ganesa had
completed her goal and ritual
and she's now immortal the problem is
that she is forced to observe eternally
it's a trade-off she gets to live on
past her body's life forever but she
isn't free to do what she wants she has
to observe the people of falgrim and
watch for the rest of her life
being immortal is too good to be true as
sister nessa soon finds out but she
seems content with it as from talking
with her she doesn't seem angry or
displeased with the outcome she is happy
as she gets to meet many wonderful
people one of whom was teal before he
passed
teles like i said we explained a baghead
story was a man who became obsessed with
tar and ended up seeing many
hallucinations
one of them was a woman who we find out
with sester gonessa
based on the context clues both of them
give us sister canessa now as explained
before
is an immortal observer watching our
every move being nowhere and anywhere at
the exact same time but she isn't the
only npc in the tower
once finding the first sacred gland upon
returning we meet thestus
thus this is one of the more confusing
npcs in this game
he gives us the foundling the ability to
let in the fog and open the frog chest
that were otherwise locked
noctiserpers and grishas roam these
areas now as opposed to the usual
brigands
he doesn't provide much more other than
that except he is related to another npc
within the game within the depths of the
seat of infinity lie a man who is down
on his luck and wanting to die but
not brave enough to push himself off the
ledge this is brother corvit and he has
the most
amount of possible misdialogue in the
game as he has a unique voice line for
every shell
and the fouling itself rather corvid
knows solomon as solomon as a scholar
and brother corvit is a priest of the
seat of infinity so the two have crossed
paths before
he has also crossed paths with haros and
eridrum horus came to the seat of
infinity and ended up becoming part of
them for a little bit of time
and then kind of serving under them
airdrim is the opposite where an eardrum
story he wanted to purge those unworthy
of the deathless doctrine and when you
meet corvid as iridrum
he asks you to finish him off as he did
his other brothers and sisters and you
can opt to kill him and push him off the
ledge yourself
teal in the foulings lines are too
important but still nice to know
teal and brother corvid's mind is like
some sort of apparition or
reaper of sorts and brother corvid knows
of the foundling like it was fate that
we were here
and what our job to do within this realm
and the outcome of it is almost like
it's predetermined brother corvid and
thestus like
i said are related they're brothers when
you talk to corvid with horus he gives
you a glimpse when you return to thestus
he gives you
his glimpse and after returning brother
carvin he sees his old memories from
destis glimpses when he was a hunter
he then leaves his ledge spot and then
the last location you can find him is in
the grisha cave by the tower where a
glimpse of a robed being can be found
dead it's unsure who killed him but
either way that's the ending of brother
corvit as he lays face down in the mud
dead brother corvette is the only
brother we can speak to and it's very
unique to the other brothers
just like the corrupted sester is very
unique compared to the other sesters of
falgrim
the corrupted sester is a sester that
resides under the steps of the seat of
infinity she wears a different mask
compared to canessa and is possible she
was branded by this as she may have been
outcasted by the church and left to fend
for herself
but seeing as there was a group of
bloodthirsty brigands nearby watching
the seat of infinity
she took refuge underneath the steps in
hopes of not being killed or caught
the corrupted sester sells us more
uncommon wares and items all of which
are useful if you do want to purchase
them there is another vendor within
falgrim however he's located at the back
of the tower and a very large gentleman
by the name of loss
boss is an elegant man he takes fashion
and commerce
very seriously bloss is accompanied by
his pet black cat which always hangs
around the shop
the most notable thing vlos possesses is
the effigy of horus but i'm going to
pass this off as something for gameplay
purposes as i really have no idea how
this would fit into anything
floss does there is only one etching
related to vlas which reads
if you're a fine gentleman please
consider vlos for all furnishings and
encounterment
it's rather perilous in these
uncivilized lands his new shop lies atop
that rustic tower
this was most likely made by vlas
himself as a way of advertising his
business which is an admirable move this
then leads us to the last
mpc the old prisoner if it wasn't
obvious before spoiler warning for him
ahead as he's one of the main npcs in
this game and if you haven't beaten the
game
i highly suggest you beat it first and
then come back and listen to this
and my past videos we've discussed about
him the old prisoner is one of the major
npcs of the game as he advances the
story
he is trapped within the tower and asks
for you to recover the glands which when
doing so should free him from the tower
the old prisoner wants to ascend but not
in the traditional way he doesn't
believe in the false truths each of the
groups preaches and praise and does
rituals with he wants to ascend but
not on their terms on his own terms so
getting the glands is the only option
for him
but since he's stuck he asks you for
help he's essentially manipulating you
but
this time's different in the boss fight
he throws out darker forms of us
this can either be played off as a
gameplay mechanic or as i see it it's
the past foundlings who were fooled by
his speech
like us but died or didn't complete
their mission we're the ones to break
that cycle by
killing him like we said before with
zester ganesa and brother corvid
both state that it's almost like fate
that we arrived and are completing these
tasks given to us
the old prisoner was once a human as by
talking to him with the solomon shell
we found out that they were brothers and
that the old prisoner became this way
as he got too greedy and ascending and
drank too much of the nectar at the seat
of infinity
was then outcasted imprisoned and then
deformed
into this burglar-like creature when the
family gets all the glands for him he
talks about all the visions he was
having of his ascension and how he's
excited to finally fulfill these visions
as he discovers these visions were of us
and not of him which is why he decides
to fight us to summarize the old
prisoner is someone who got greedy with
nectar at the seat of infinity
cast it out because of the drinking of
too much nectar is forbidden within the
church
deformed into a birdlike creature had
hallucinations of his ascension
and like we stated before used to be a
human thanks to his relationship with
solomon
he was then imprisoned in the tower
waiting for the next naive soul to let
him free
and when he finally became free and
ready to ascend and fulfill his dreams
and visions
he realized those visions were fake and
he was having them about
us ascending and not him and now that he
is furious he plans to kill us so that
nobody can ascend
as he cannot that is the lore of every
mpc in mortal shell
like i said some of these are going to
be more in depth than others but that's
just how it is not everything can be
evenly split
let me know what you think about this
video in the comments down below thank
you for joining me through this journey
of the npcs of mortal shell
and take care everyone and until next
time goodbye
[Music]
you